well welcome back i regret to announce
halfway harry and the preaching princess
pinocchio are back in the uk banging on
about the usual stuff whining moaning
preaching about quality poverty usual
thing uh my question is what are they
doing here here's a little clip not much
because we're not really that interested
but have a listen to this
it is
very nice to be back in the uk have any
of you today so far had that feeling
that pinch me moment where you just go
how am i here yes how are you here and
why are you here
all you've done is trash this country
trashed the royals trashed the monarchy
and upset the queen what are you doing
here well lawyer paula rhone adrian and
talk to the contributor esther crack
over here so paula
why why are they here
they hate this country they hate the
royal family they've disowned the royal
family they hate the monarchy and all it
stands for they keep their royal titles
and fleece them for hundreds of millions
of dollars to the highest bidder what
are they doing back here okay so first
of all they were invited
secondly i've never heard them say that
they hate this country i've never heard
them say they hate the world family and
i know
that the facts are very important to you
peers so let's deal with the facts they
are working they are here to benefit
you they're earning their netflix money
they're being followed by netflix
everywhere they go so they're doing
their charity work they're coming along
patting people on the head so that
netflix can record it for their
lovey-dovey documentary which they're
getting paid by the way yes i'm told
over a hundred million dollars for this
world doing charity work is equivalent
to you patting somebody they don't do
any duty they abandon the country they
abandon royal duty but they want to keep
the titles they want to fleece the
titles
i'm just not having this yeah i think
it's complete double standard they are
damaging the monarchy with every
interview they give chips chip away
meghan markle we're all a bunch of
racists apparently british journalists
called her child the n word no evidence
apparently someone in the royal family
expressed concern about archie skin
color no evidence
and so on she sprays out this stuff
damaging the monarchy damaging the
country no evidence ever gets produced
but i think she's holding the royal
family hostage with that because if
you've if you've been a victim of racist
abuse why don't you name the person
because you know if you don't say who it
is you're tarnishing that the you're
painting the royal family with that
brush but my question is isn't harry
the royal family have you ever been a
victim of racist oh i have actually and
have you always named oh absolutely
i've been a victim of racist abuse i
know exactly who the people are who have
racially abused me i know i know where
they're working i know what they're
doing and to date i haven't named them
because i will be told where is my proof
and no doubt there are a number of you
no no no no no no no
watching this now appears who will say
to you that i am suffering bullying well
i'm being victimized at work but no one
here believes actually
well actually it's funny the biggest
allegations of bullying
against any member of the royal family
were against meghan markle against two
pas who apparently were bullied so much
they had to leave but here's
every single day they went to work so
that you know she denied it
this is what i've been told
what you were told where is the evidence
and this is what we have to be careful
about because we want to have a very
dignified discussion about this we don't
want to do this backwards
and this is what happens and that's the
only basis that we have
if you were a victim
you were invited they were invited they
were invited of course they were invited
because charities want publicity my
point is they are bringing a netflix
camera crew this is why william won't
see them this is why charles isn't seen
that's why the queen won't see them they
don't trust them they don't trust them
not to put it all on camera to put it
all in harry's tell book where he'll
cause even more misery for the royal
family and i think at what point does
this stop these two apparently
these two apparently left the country
because they wanted privacy i can agree
with you on the fear that charles and
william are probably grappling with at
the moment because you're absolutely
right haron and megan will not be
silenced they will not be saying but
hold on they feel that they have been
hurt and i don't know whether they have
they can feel as if they've been hurt
and they will not be suffering
let me make one thing clear they can
bang on in public as much as they like
they just can't do it as the duke and
duchess of sussex as members of the
royal family strip them of the titles
they can yap away and by the way their
market value would go
well why shouldn't she notice hold on
why shouldn't she name her racially
abused her because that's a very strong
accusation i agree last word should be
gratitude you're going to accuse me
you're here because of megan and i know
you're grateful about that i'm here
because that is actually true i wouldn't
be doing this so that meghan markle's
thank you megan